une petite croix rouge malhabilement
dessinée au feutre en guise de plaques
de médecins ici dans cet appartement de
belleville la médecine dispensait
n'était qu'une médecine de fortune
illégal les policiers des renseignements
généraux ont levé le voile sur une bien
triste réalité celle des sans papiers
chinois
soigné par deux ponts est très bon
marché et propose aux pratiques dans
notre siècle
venus des campagnes chinoises les
clandestins étaient des proies faciles
ne savent pas la langue qu'ils ne
connaissent pas qui n'a aucune
information qui ne te connaissent pas
les lois en france et c'est donc quand
ils ont quelque chose c'est de bouche à
oreille et ils vont voir justement leurs
compatriotes des compatriotes qui
n'hésitait pas à pratiquer des
avortements à plus de dix semaines avec
des aiguilles de 40 centimètres des
aiguilles saisis par la police comme de
grosses quantités de médicaments
importés illégalement de chine est
totalement interdite en france et en
principe l'exercice illégal de la
médecine et réprimés par le code pénal
et les pratiques qui semblent avoir été
mises en jeu à jour relève de pratiques
criminelles
en tout six cabinets démanteler
gynécologue son diplôme dentiste
amateurs ophtalmologistes improvisé
opérons tous dans le quartier chinois de
belleville
les enquêteurs ont arrêté dix neuf
personnes quatre soigneur seront
présentés devant le juge
un acupuncteur a été mise en examen et
écrouée